-I had a great night
last night.
I went out to, uh --
I went to Carbone.
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
So I went with a my friend
Mike Birbiglia,
a very funny comedian, and we're
talking about stand-up,
and he's like -- he's like,
"Yeah, you should
do stand-up again."
And I go, yeah, I know,
because I did start my career
in stand-up, and I go,
I just haven't been on stage
in probably 10 years.
And, you know,
Chris Rock tells me
I should do stand-up again.
And I go, "Yeah, I know.
I just got to get an act
and blah, blah, blah."
He goes, "You should go
to the Comedy Cellar
and just go up," and I go,
"I know, I know.
So I don't have an act."
And he's like,
"Let's just walk down there
and just -- just break
the ice of -- just the myth
of just going on stage
at the thing."
I go, "Yeah, okay."
So I went,
and it's an amazing club.
I go, "Yeah,
I totally remember it."
And you go down the stairs
and the whole thing,
and there's a great comedian,
Tina Friml, was on.
So I went and watched her set.
It was awesome.
And then I go, "All right,
I'm gonna leave."
And I went in the hallway,
and Chris Rock
is sitting on the stairs.
He's like...
"I knew you'd come back.
I knew you'd come back.
You have to come back
to stand-up.
You've got to do it, man.
I knew it.
I knew you'd come back."
I go -- and I felt
like the comedy gods
were just telling me,
like, "Yeah,
you should do stand-up again."
So I go, "Yeah."
I go, "Are you going up?"
And he's like, "Yeah,
maybe I'll go up."
So he surprised the audience.
Chris Rock gets up,
surprised the audience,
and destroys.
He's unbelievable.
And so then I went up
to give him a bottle of water,
like as a goof,
and everyone started clapping.
And then he goes, he took
the microphone, and he goes...
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Wow."
So I did stand-up
for the first time last night
in 10 years.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was unbelievable.
I totally remembered it.
It was super fun.
It was great.
I was like --
I don't even know --
I don't know what I was
talking about.
We just made it --
He made me so comfortable
up there.
But I remember, like,
"Oh, yeah,
it's so fun to be onstage."
And when a joke works,
the crowd loves it.
I mean, like, the monologue.
[ Laughter ]
-And when it doesn't.
-And when it doesn't work,
you know, it's silence,
and, uh...
No, but I do remember that.
The room gets hot, you know,
when you tell a good joke,
and then it's like...
And then it like,
comes down to room temperature.
I loved it.
Anyways, I got the bug,
and I wanted
to thank -- thank Chris.
Thanks, Mike.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, Comedy Cellar.
I got to --
I'll work on an act.
-Yeah.
-I'm gonna work on an act,
and I'll be out there,
because I want to go out
around the country.
I want to say hi to everybody
and all the fans.
I love meeting people, and I
think it's gonna be fun.
I'll do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, it's Halloween.
Give me a couple months.
I'll work on something.
-Couple months.